>>Our goal today is to figure
out if we are going to buy,
sell or hold the security that we've
already purchased in the portfolio.
>>Narrator: Many teachers use
fictional stock portfolios
to help students hone math skills.
>>Connie: You bought Disney
at thirty-five dollars
and fourteen cents.
Where is it now?
>>Narrator: But at the
Ariel Community Academy
on Chicago's South Side, students
have a vested interest in learning
because they're risking real money.
>>Connie: What are our options?
>>Narrator: Lots of it.
>>Student: I say hold because
this one went up a dollar
and now it may go up even more
in another period of time.
>>Narrator: Each Ariel class receives
an endowment of 20,000 dollars
which they begin to actively
manage in sixth grade.
>>James: I'll say hold it because you
sell it right now all you're doing is
making basically like
a dollar profit.
>>Narrator: When they graduate
eighth grade the class donates half
of their profits to charity.
Each student receives an equal
share of the remaining profits,
usually just over 100 dollars
to invest on their own.
>>James: The money I
make with investments,
I will put that towards some
the college tuition and all
that because I know that's very
expensive, laptops, books, classes.
>>Narrator: This unique public school
private business partnership was
created by financier John Rogers.
>>John: What would be
the reason to buy a stock
after it's going down
a lot like that?
>>Narrator: And Chicago's
schools' Chief, Arne Duncan.
>>Arne Duncan: Ariel was how I
got my start in public education.
I ran John Rogers'
nonprofit the Ariel Foundation
for about six years starting in 1992.
And in 1995 we were young
and dumb enough to think
that we could create
a great public school.
>>Student: So let the stock grow
and then you can sell
it and make more money.
>>John: We think by exposing our
African American boys and girls
to the stock market at an
early age it's really helping
to enhance their math skills.
>>Narrator: Ariel's test scores
have soared over the past five years
with 88 percent of the students
exceeding state standards in math.
>>John: If you think about it, if
you're picking stocks or having
to understand about growth rates
and percentage growth rates year
over year and quarter by quarter
there's just so much math involved.
And so I think it's just natural
for our kids to be doing so well now
that they've been exposed to the
markets over a long period of time.
>>Mariah Sheriff: Can someone
tell me what's their decision?
>>Narrator: Exposure to the
financial literacy curriculum starts
in kindergarten and echoes across
every subject in every grade.
>>Student: It would have
an opportunity cost to go
to circusland or buy a new TV.
>>Mariah Sheriff: Very
good, can you say that big,
big word you just used again?
>>Student: Opportunity cost.
>>Mariah Sheriff: Opportunity
cost and that's what we have
when we have a decision
to make, right?
>>Teachers always look for the real
world application of their curriculum
and I don't ever have to do that.
It's never a search for
why this is going to apply?
It's just a matter of
making it so engaging
that they will take it
home and talk about it.
>>And what is it called when
you put money in your bank?
>>Everybody: Deposit.
>>Mariah Sheriff: I'm going
to teach personal finance.
I'm going to teach investments
and in seventh grade we talk
about international trade and we
talk about foreign exchange market
and how that's a thriving market
that our kids might be involved in.
>>Student: One of the negatives is
that they probably have
some more competition.
>>Connie: They're just
not regurgitating a set
of vocabulary words.
They actually are looking out
into their community and trying
to understand their place in it
and processing that information.
>>James: Yeah, plus they global
because they got Hong Kong Disney,
they got California Disneyland.
>>Connie: There are some students
in the classroom that are saying
"You know I want to be
an entrepreneur one day."
>>Humu: Before I took this class
I said I wanted to be a doctor.
Then I wanted to be a nurse, then I
wanted to be this, a brain surgeon,
but since, after a while I see
that this is my favorite class.
I like picking stocks and working
for myself so instead of working
for somebody else I would
like to be an entrepreneur.
>>Raven: And my business
is called Bling Things.
I put rhinestones on
accessories and electronics.
>>Narrator: As a culminating activity
eighth graders apply what they've
learned about marketing, income
projections, and other aspects
of creating a business by writing
and presenting business plans.
>>Student: My market segment was
we target the 70 percent of gamers
who request professional
aid when gaming.
Our target customer was any
gamer holding a vested interest
in mastering the games they owned.
>>Teacher: Okay now both
plans are pretty good.
But the end all of both
business plans must be the return
on investments.
>>Judith K. Shelton: This curriculum
is not just about investing.
It's also about a long-term
partnership on the part of a company
in the immediate lives
of children and families.
>>Woman: So how was
your day today, guys?
>>Student: Good.
>>Judith K. Shelton: There
are values of that company
that children themselves have seen:
the idea of honest enterprise,
the idea of looking
for an opportunity
to change and benefit one's self.
>>Matthew Yale: Ariel is a
very unique place to work.
We have people who really
are committed to more
than just their day-to-day jobs.
Employees are here at the building
tutoring, planning the garden,
any type of project that needs
to be done so we have between 20
and 25 employees who are
helping out in the school.
>>What stock did you pick?
I forgot.
>>Student: I picked Sony.
>>Matthew Yale: Yeah, why?
>>Student: Because I looked at Sony's
competitor which was [Inaudible].
>>Matthew Yale: Okay.
>>It's an extraordinary opportunity
to really be making a difference
in the public education system.
>>John: So you want to
walk on through now.
>>Narrator: At the end of the year
Ariel students visited the corporate
headquarters of McDonalds to
mingle with other shareholders
and executives at the
company's annual meeting.
>>John: And without
further ado, Don Thompson,
President of McDonalds, U.S.A.
>>Every year we try to have one
of the [inaudible] African
American executives come in and talk
with the kids and hopefully
be a role model for the kind
of successful business
people they can emulate.
>>Don Thompson: When I was your age,
I didn't even know what a stock was.
Let alone to be able
to get some education
and begin to understand business.
And so I'm impressed
with what you all do.
I hope you know that what you
are doing is very special.
I wanted to take a couple
of minutes to open it up,
answer any questions you
have you could ask me.
>>Student: Do you pick stocks?
If so, what type?
>>Don Thompson: First of
all, I'm jealous, see.
I don't have nearly the knowledge
you all have about the market.
I don't study it the same way you do.
>>This kind of education sets
them up for the business world.
It sets them up for
international ventures.
It helps them become more rounded
and they create aspirations
within themselves to do
something so great that many
of us could never even imagine it.
>>Student: Was it hard to
become what you are now?
>>Don Thompson: Is it hard?
It's only as hard as you make it
if you're not focused on today.
Be focused on being
the best you can today.
Everything else takes care of itself.
>>Narrator: For more
information on what works
in public education
go to edutopia.org.